b
das war das war jetzt echt ein kleiner
schock du hast mich die ganze zeit an
der nase herumgeführt das macht man
nicht aber es hat mir spaß gemacht weil
es mir ruhig frühjahr sagen können es
zwei brückmann media arbeitet dann erst
aber nur halb so lustig gewesen
hahaha und du arbeitest bei brückmann
media als junior creative director und
jetzt stellst du mir euer konzert vor
überzeugen mich ich bin gespannt auf
eure ideen dann zieh dich warm an
wir gehen nämlich groß
den
guten morgen zahnbürste also der slogan
bilden fürs leben ist ja nicht ganz so
knackig den haben wir uns auch nicht
ausgedacht
er kommt vom
bundeswirtschaftsministerium damit
müssen wir arbeiten weiß ich doch
deswegen habe ich das gesagt
also wenn wir eine kampagne rund um das
thema jugend und ausbildung organisieren
dann denkt man es kommen nicht nur junge
leute sondern auch firmen die sich um
die förderpreise bewerben sollte kids
und ältere geschäftsleute gleichermaßen
anspricht verstehe
trotzdem liegt unser fokus aber auf
jungen leuten und unsere kampagne soll
genau diese zielgruppe ansprechen weil
die firmen die kommen von allein ab wenn
wir genug leute erreichen das ist
richtig
nur ist das thema ausbildung nicht
wirklich auf deswegen müssten mehr
zielgruppenorientiert denken und die
menschen genau dort abholen wo sie
stehen
die kommen
so wie diese beiden sie versuchen mit
ihrer musik andere zu inspirieren
also bei mir funktioniert
abschnitt
von mir ist jedenfalls nicht das ist
klar
sehr witzig von mir auch nicht das
wusste ich ja wohl
bist du dir ganz sicher herzlichen
glückwunsch bruderherz du wirst vater